foreign
this Saturday night Alberta's escalating
firefight residents on edge is extreme
heat settles in it takes a lot of
resources it's hot hard Dirty Work the
situation volatile the losses stacking
up as conditions deteriorate part of our
party room it was a family room
visit to the Vatican
Pope Francis and president zielinski's
peace plan to help Ukraine's most
vulnerable victims
repairing a throwaway Society I've
gotten quotes for boards that are more
than three quarters the price of the
product the unaffordable options and
calls to fix a broken system
global national with para Nasser
good evening to you and thank you for
joining us we're going to begin tonight
with the erupting Wildfire emergency in
Alberta where the crisis is expected to
escalate this weekend as unseasonably
hot and dry weather hits the concern the
arrival of a heat Dome that many fear
will fuel the situation albertans
understandably are on edge as even more
people in the province's fire zones are
being told to prepare to leave at a
moment's notice
right now there are around 80 active
wildfires burning across Northern and
central Alberta about a quarter are out
of control Environment Canada has
blanketed all of Alberta and much of
neighboring BC under heat advisories
temperatures are forecast to climb in
the low 30s for the next several days
that's 10 to 15 degrees above the
seasonal norm and the smoke from those
wildfires and NBC Saskatchewan and
Manitoba is now impacting air quality
across much of Canada
the Searing heat threat of lightning
strikes and fierce winds will likely
ignite and fan even more raging fires
Marty blunt is near Entwistle west of
Edmonton and she has our top story
tonight's morning
pharah there are about 80 wildfires in
Alberta many of them burning out of
control here in Parkland County
residents have been able to return home
but the situation here remains delicate
and the community is still on edge
a haze of smoke clouding the air
smoldering ground with trees turned to
use matchsticks homes reduced to rubble
and Ash devastating scenes of a wildfire
in Alberta's Parkland and Yellowhead
counties here was sort of my pride and
joy it's a it's a 79 Cadillac with 76
000k on it
right there
last Saturday Archie and Donna Lee came
home to a nightmare after they were
forced to leave two days earlier yeah
everything burnt a home full of memories
now gone and that was our uh a Breezeway
in the middle that was sort of our party
room it was a family room type of thing
nearby fire crews are still working
around the clock fighting hot spots and
the wind shifted a bit and pushed that
fire this way the sad part is to jump
the river right all through here and
many homes on that side were lost and
with high temperatures wind Tinder dry
conditions and the fire deeply embedded
into peat moss in the ground they're
bracing for the worst well our concerns
with the fire today is low humidity high
temps and that's a real good day for
fire growth and that's what our crews
are being mindful of in there the chief
says crews are exhausted and hoping for
relief it takes a lot of resources it's
hot hard dirty work it's tough drilling
a couple of days ahead of us we really
hope those incoming resources are
distributed to the places that need it
and while the evacuation orders have
been lifted the Parkland mayor is still
warning residents to be ready to leave
again on a moment's notice this fire is
still active and it is still very
concerning we are encouraging residents
to be prepared to have a bag ready
enough food and water for three days all
of their medications and important
documents as for Donna and Archie Lee
they plan on rebuilding they're grateful
for the support from their community and
local church and are focusing on what
matters most we've lost everything but
I'm glad I still have Archie
because I've had lots of bad things
happen during my lifetime and
this is the most devastating but we have
each other
and that's all that really matters
officials and neighboring Yellowhead
counties say there are still two fires
of concern near Wildwood and Evansburg
fire officials also say while there are
no active fires here there is still
concern as the peat moss is burning
deeper into the ground which heightens
the risk of the trees reigniting and the
fire spreading even further pharah
Marnie blunt near Entwistle Alberta
thanks for that Marnie stay safe out
there neighboring BC is also bracing for
extreme summer like temperatures it's
only May and already there are more than
40 active wildfires burning across that
Province parts of BC's and Central and
Southern interior have been dealing with
flooding sparked by record spring heat
and a fast-melting snowpack and there is
potential for more high stream flows as
temperatures rise the good news is
officials say this heat wave won't be as
hot as the deadly heat Dome that hit the
province's Lower Mainland in June of
2021.
it was a meeting that came at a critical
time Ukrainian president vlodimir
zielinski met with Pope Francis today
for their first face-to-face since
Russia invaded Ukraine last year as
tariya Israel reports the talks come
during a pivotal moment in the conflict
but some political experts believe the
meeting is long overdue
Pope Francis welcomed Vladimir zielinski
to the Vatican in what's being
considered the Ukrainian president's
most delicate stop on a packed trip the
two spoke privately for 40 minutes with
the Pope underscoring the need to
protect the most innocent victims of the
war this meeting should have happened
earlier
um but and I think it's a it's a big
victory uh for uh for the Ukrainian
president Francis has tried to position
himself as a possible Peacemaker
zelenski recently invited him to Kiev
but the pope said he would only go on
the condition he also visits Moscow an
approach some political experts call
counterproductive it is not really
possible to broker a peace deal when
Russia wants to conquer Ukraine the
Italian government offered its full
support with prime minister Georgia
Maloney vowing to back Ukraine as long
as necessary we discussed our cooperate
particularly security and Military
cooperation said zelenski his visit to
Rome comes at a crucial time Ukrainian
forces are advancing towards the eastern
city of bakmut ahead of a widely
anticipated counter-offensive this
political scientist originally from
Ukraine believes zelenski's travels are
in Preparation this is a continuation of
visits from zelenski in order to get the
public support and weapons and
ammunition for new content offensive in
this world is Russia the Ukrainian
president's next stop is Germany where
the government revealed it will provide
three billion dollars in weapons and
equipment to Ukraine the largest Aid
package since the War Began and there
will likely be more Aid coming prime
minister Justin Trudeau is preparing to
travel to South Korea on Monday for the
G7 where he and other world leaders are
expected to discuss boosting support for
Ukraine and ramping up pressure on
Russia to end the war pharah Korea isri
and Ottawa thank you for that Sharia
Palestinian militants in Israel have
agreed to a ceasefire ending a fifth day
of fighting
[Music]
[Applause]
tonight people celebrated as news of
that ceasefire spread just hours ago
plumes of smoke Rose above Gaza City
rocket launches from Gaza followed
bombing by Israeli aircraft of Islamic
Jihad targets Egypt was able to mediate
a truce ending clashes that left 35
people dead Israeli forces first
launched an airstrike campaign in the
early hours of Tuesday accusing Islamic
Jihad leadership of planning attacks on
Israel
recent headlines surrounding Canada and
China are highlighting issues within our
security culture on this week's the West
block host Mercedes Stevenson spoke to
experts about the need to update
Canada's national security strategy amid
Chinese foreign interference blenders
Mercedes Pharaoh there's no question
that Canada is operating in an
increasingly dangerous world and
Canadians are targets for foreign
Espionage and intimidation just ask MP
Michael Chong who found out that he and
his family were being targeted by the
People's Republic of China will spy
versus spy isn't new there has been a
high level of concern over the targeting
of a parliamentarian's family and
questions about why that information
never made its way into the hands of the
Prime Minister or his National Security
advisors instead seemingly getting lost
in a bureaucratic maze Vincent Rigby the
former National Security adviser to the
Prime Minister says the recent
Revelations highlight problems in
Canada's national security culture and
oversight calling it a collective
failure in terms of who's to blame with
respect to Mr Chong and what's happening
here I mean I know that for politicians
there's a natural inclination to try and
hold one person to one institution
accountable in in my view that when
something like this happens it's a
collective failure Rigby says that while
Canadian spies need updated information
tools and oversight the problems are
starting with our politicians and their
disinterest in National Security I would
say the problem strikes at the political
level and and I think that at the
political level it's not taken as
seriously as it probably should until
there's a major major crisis former
thesis director Ward Alcock found the
Chong case less concerning saying China
commonly spies on critics of the regime
but echoed the concern about politicians
lack of understanding when it comes to
National Security issues our politicians
are really not very experienced in
dealing with National Security issues uh
and and frankly would often prefer not
to deal with them that lack of
familiarity and maturity when it comes
to intelligence is a problem across
parties according to both Rigby and
elcock but Rigby contends politicians
could do more to make sure sensitive
information is being seen and properly
considered right now I think part of the
problem we're having with foreign
interference is that you're getting all
this Intel but it's going up the chain
in a very disparate way we'll have more
on what needs to change for Canada to be
able to deal with spies and protect
Canadians tomorrow on the west walk
Farah
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thank you
Mercedes
food inflation continues to outpace
overall inflation in Canada leading many
to wonder why the price of Supply
managed items like milk butter and eggs
are so high and gaviola has more on
whether this complex system is doing
what it's supposed to
and at the bakery obviously we use a ton
of butter every day so we use minimum 15
kilo butter per day Maxine Bauer owns a
French restaurant bar and bakery she
tells Global News the price of eggs has
increased more than 50 percent in two
years Butters up more than 70 percent
Dairy eggs and poultry are all Supply
managed in Canada this system was born
out of a difficult time for farmers in
the 60s technological advances meant
poultry egg and Dairy Producers
struggled with oversupply and low
unstable prices leading to disputes
between farmers and processors Farmers
banded together to ask provincial
governments to create marketing boards
which led to the supply management
system its aim to ensure stable prices
for farmers and consumers to this day
provincial boards are responsible for
setting prices under this Federal
program
Supply management also limits Imports
which would compete with Canadian
products this complex system is
polarizing some defend it by pointing to
peer countries where inflation has been
much higher food inflation based on
Supply management is minimal despite
what people may think and it works very
very effectively so as to prevent
overproduction Canada is the only
country where Supply management remains
this food Economist says there's a price
to pay for this system
for consumers it will it likely costs
them more money but not as much more as
as some people would argue the other
thing it does though is provides much
more predictability in prices many
experts say it's not perfect but it
helps Canada through the avian flu
outbreak in Canada we actually had to
slaughter about I think a little less
than 2 a million Birds when whereas in
the U.S they had to slaughter over 60
million birds and and egg prices went up
60 percent in Canada egg prices went up
I think about 17 percent as a result
Supply management may be mitigating food
inflation but costs are still rising and
someone has to eat that cost but
mercen's conscience won't let her use
anything else if I substitute it will be
maybe less expensive for us but the
quality will not be the same and this is
all our point to be doing good food good
taste with good product and gaviola
Global News Toronto
Ontario Provincial Police Sergeant Eric
Mueller made his final trip home today
the procession made its way from Ottawa
to Rockland along Highway 17.
Mueller died of his injuries after he
was shot early Thursday in an ambush in
burjet the 42-year-old was responding to
a call about a family disturbance with
two other officers who were injured but
survived a police funeral for Mueller
will be held on Thursday at the Canadian
Tire Center 39 year old balfoury has
been charged with first-degree murder
and two charges of attempted murder
horror tornadoes wreak havoc in the U.S
coming up the death and destruction
after more than two dozen Twisters
touched down
parts of the U.S are in recovery mode
after a potential 30 tornadoes moved
across several States leaving at least
one person dead in Texas
in Oklahoma Heavy Rain strong wind gusts
and hail were also reported buildings
were damaged and power lines brought
down Nebraska saw grapefruit-sized hail
the damage is consistent with tornadoes
but forecasters are expected to confirm
the exact number today
archaeologists have discovered a 4 000
year old temple in Western Peru the set
is about 75 kilometers north of Lima
it's believed people carried out
religious cult ceremonies in the
u-shaped Temple archaeologists also
found a carving of an ancient cross
symbol which is now the oldest complete
representation found in the Andes
[Music]
I had the fight to fix why it's so
difficult to repair our aging
Electronics
[Music]
with inflation driving up the cost off
everything it's more important than ever
to have things that last but whether
it's phones or kitchen appliances you've
likely had a hard time getting products
repaired on this week's the new reality
Krista Hesse looks at what some see as a
broken system for maintaining what we
own and the growing movement to fix it
fixing the circuit boards that power
electronic devices is delicate work
replacing tiny control chips some
smaller than a fingernail can be all
that's needed
but as John Fidel knows All Too Well
Repair these days is never that simple I
have far more uh difficulty repairing a
modern piece of equipment just for the
fact of Parts availability I can't get
the parts in my hand instead
manufacturers will offer him an entirely
new circuit board but at a price I've
gotten quotes for boards that are more
than three quarters the price of the
product
Fidel says he'll spend hours searching
for a more affordable option making it
more likely the customer will choose to
repair manufacturers used to sell parts
over the last 20 30 years they've
systematically stopped doing that
and that led Kyle Wiens to start iFixit
a website that offers repair guides
tools and parts we're hoping that we can
end this throwaway Society by making all
the things that we have last longer a
recent survey found just 18 percent of
Canadians had their last broken
electronic device or Home Appliance
repaired the biggest barriers cost and
the inability to fix their products more
and more these days we get products from
manufacturers and they don't have a plan
for us to be able to maintain it the
right to repair movement wants to change
that right to repair is the idea that if
you bought it you should be able to fix
it
they're pushing to pass laws that would
force manufacturers to provide
information and parts to everyone a game
changer for independent shops like
fidels
Advocates say in order to fix all our
devices we first need to repair the
system Krista Hesse Global News Now
Toronto hockey fans are definitely
feeling sour today the Maple Leafs had
finally made it to the second round of
the NHL playoffs breaking a nearly
20-year curse but of course despite that
they still lost the Series to the
Florida Panthers getting knocked out of
the running for the Stanley Cup
yet again and with one Canadian team
left it's renewing questions on whether
or not we'll see a cup on this side of
the Border anytime soon here's Easton
ham
a sea of blue jerseys
and blue emotions coming out of maple
leaf Square Friday night after a
heartbreaking loss for Toronto fans it
sucks man like they they make us go
through this every year like yeah we
made through the first round but I
honestly thought that we got this we got
decision like six games despite so much
hope and a star started lineup it's
still familiar territory for the blue
and white you have the hope that
everything's gonna work out and every
single year it never ever ever ever ever
does a fight to the very end according
to the Leaf's star players
I don't think I believe Denver wavered
uh oh not even saying it but I'm gonna
see uh you know we can get the job done
enough for us but we got a lot of belief
in this group we got a lot of belief in
that core and
yeah
it sucks right now but yeah please
1967 the year the Leafs last won the
Stanley Cup despite this number like
always fans remain hopeful
we took a step in the right direction
and now it's just about uh you know
taking what you learned this year in how
to win a playoff series and putting it
all together again next year but as one
Canadian team Falls there is still hope
for another to win the Stanley Cup the
Edmonton Oilers now holding the weight
of the country on its shoulders
now trailing the Las Vegas golden
knights three to two but oil country not
worried about a spill foreign
history wouldn't be made oil in seven
let's go definitely oil like we're
winning let's go for many Canadians
seeing the Oilers raise Lord Stanley
wouldn't be something to celebrate but
it's been three decades since the
Stanley Cup has been hoisted north of
the border so the question remains is
this the year the cop comes home Eastern
him Global News
fingers crossed that's global national
for this Saturday night I'm foreign
Aster on behalf of our whole crew here I
want to thank you for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's your
Canada is pouch Cove and you've been
landed Labrador tomorrow Jeff sempel
will be at the anchor desk wishing all
the mothers out there a very happy
Mother's Day tomorrow have a good night
foreign